his documentary work on Tower Records
and the Eagles of Death Metal notes on
me are worth your watch she's an
outstanding director and documentarian
and now a man who's gonna be selling
handkerchiefs as well as getting back in
life and pieces on CBS season 4 great to
see my good buddy to see my strength did
I hit it all did I get it all yeah I
think so I also you know take my kids to
school every day too so rate you too
kind of hard damn streets a lot of work
so now do you do you drop off do you go
in by drop-off do you stop the car no I
have a little extra button and the door
opens and then the ejector seats just go
like that and I got to make sure that
the big kid is on you know the driver's
side because that body mass really helps
the younger one out the door it's a
weighted system yeah yeah it's
scientifically proven impressive yeah
you really and then you go right to work
the right to work and you do all of that
yeah and then so let's talk a little
sports first yes please what the hell
happened with the Tampa Bay Lightning I
mean did they touch the Presidents
Trophy I mean I honestly III I don't
know I'm shocked when you threw up that
statistic of games lost per month right
that is one of the most impressive like
stat sheets I've ever seen from from a
hockey team or really a professional
sports team period right to be that
dominant for that long throughout the
course of an entire season is in and of
itself impressive the only thing that is
more impressive is just how quickly they
were swept out of the NHL playoffs I
mean there's absolutely just I'm shocked
I bet you they didn't touch the
president Presidents Trophy cuz teams
don't do that right I mean if you've
ever seen Belichick being handed the AFC
Champions it's like put ya on the hood
of somebody's car I don't know I don't
even want to touch people most people
don't and you know I mean I'm a big
believer and don't buy playoff hats or
shirts if you're a fan cuz you're not
you don't want to celebrate that you
made the playoffs you want to celebrate
that you won the thing maybe that's what
happened with my Michigan Wolverines go
into the sweet 16 game I bought
something about said Michigan sweet
singing
no you had an iron ship so it's not them
it's me absolutely it's your fault no
surprise Susie hasn't told you that she
wasn't there to stop me I'm yeah III
can't believe that the Tampa gotta got
swept but you know I mean to be quite
honest even just in the last few years
yes
the team that gets that Presidents
Trophy it's it's not a great thing right
it really is not that great a thing
especially in the playoffs
it is a streaky luck based system
practically yes in terms of clicking at
the right time hitting your peak at the
right time because that the Stanley Cup
Playoffs that they are grueling have you
Colin Hanks ever drank from the cup I
have oh my gosh and it was it was what
did you may ask what you drank from the
cup I'm pretty sure it was like a Molson
ice or something you're some Canadian
brew I'm sure it had to be Canadian yeah
no it was it was absolutely incredible I
mean when your team finally wins the
Stanley Cup and you've spent your entire
life rooting for that team yes and then
it happens a you you cry like you the
little kid you were when you went to
your first game right my wife took
photos of course yes luckily they have
been deleted but then when you actually
get a moment you know to be able to just
see the Stanley Cup in person and and
and then you know one of the players
goes hey you want to drink out of it I
mean it's it's just it's your--it's
kidding no just childhood you're not
allowed to have it
you didn't you not a lot of that tip it
yourself though right that's where tips
it tipped it for you on Jay cope it's up
nose well on Jay did I drink from it a
few times if I'm being so you water
skiing no it was Dustin Penner was the
first time Dustin Dustin Penner was in
Kopitar and then kopi did the second
time now yeah I mean when you're around
the cup there are rules so very serious
bar
rules very serious rules and young and
the only one you can't host it either
right unless you've wanted or correct as
I understand it you know it people say
you can't hoist it over your head my
shoulders unless you're a player but
that's obviously not true because you
know the equipment managers the head
coaches sure a lot of them do that so I
think it's it's an organizational type a
role you you have to have some role
within that organization to be able to
do it but they're they're probably not
going to let Jim from accounting do that
[Laughter]
sounds like office space yeah Jim just
uh you know did you get the memo so
again for mere mortals no hoisting no
tipping but drinking is absolutely good
and you did that yeah I did it fantastic
Colin Hanks here on the Rich Eisen show
I don't even know how to get to it so
I'll just get to it you're outdoors your
love of the outdoors yes you you camp
yes camping yeah it's been reignited to
hear you talk about your your your
camping and the but you tent camping rig
well your rig yeah just get your get
someone in your life who loves you as
much as Colin Hanks loves talking about
his camping I have a a rack on the top
of my of my SUV and on that rack is a a
tent that can fold out and it has a
little ladder and yeah it's its rooftop
camping so basically the you know people
ask great what is the point of that the
point you were the point is just so that
you don't have to go to just like the
the designated camping spots this idea
that you can actually go out into the
backwoods and survive camp anywhere and
then pack up and go that's that's the
idea and and you've done this by
yourself I've done it by myself yeah
I've done it I've done it with some
friends it's I love it I absolutely
there's something about getting the gear
and doing all that great outdoors and
just doing the great outdoors just
staring into a fire like you're looking
into the abyss trying to figure out
life's answers has an animal ever
no disturbed no because you're on the
roof of your
yes I'm on the roof of my car yes of
course if you ever would you ever do
something like that absolutely not see I
don't know so here's the downside and it
actually has nothing to do with camping
yes I almost couldn't park in your
structure today because this is RIT
because of the rig I can't go into a
majority of underground parking
structure what does he take the ring off
means that's a two-person job and my
wife's not gonna help with that we ready
to camp in a moment's notice
yeah I'm ready to camp at a moment's
notice but I have to get to an
appointment 20 minutes early to find
parking that's that's what the is there
such a hole in is there such a thing as
spontaneous camping yes
that's just like where it's just like if
I had if I'd say I didn't have the
schedule release show to do on the NFL
Network tonight 8:00 Eastern Time with
me using this conversation to try and
get in a plug for something I'm doing
later if I didn't have to do it and you
had your rest of your day free yes we
could just go you could just say he rich
let's go let's go camp let's do it yeah
it would be me and you in some sort of
like you know planes trains and
automobiles the great outdoors how about
them bears opening up the season
guaranteed we don't we don't camp with
two pillows so we're not gonna have that
fasting all right Colin Hanks here on
the Richard show so we've done this
before and and I'd like to say it's a
tradition unlike any other where explain
to me again if you don't mind setting up
of course the the NFL coach as
stepfather yes many years ago I was
watching an NFL game with my father
hmm actually no it was a it was a
college game because it was Charlie Weis
when he was head coach Charlie Weis is
that George Washington George Washington
of this game and my dad they were they
had a shot of him and my dad just said I
wonder what kind of stepfather he would
be like and the game was born so we
basically look at head coaches and then
we try and come up with like what is the
phrase or like the go-to move
that step font to their stepchild or
stepchild oh yeah always to the
stepchild do you recall what Charlie
Weiss's I do not recall well charlie
weis I said that's now how often you
played this it's it's like like Abraham
Lincoln just lost to the ages to stick
with the presidential fish so we figured
we would just I think one time we even
did this for Jim Tomsula that's how long
we've been doing this and coughlin
I forget what conflict auslan was
slugger who was the guy who says pass me
the clicker no it's not passed with the
clicker you were wondering who he's
always this stuff that where's the
clicker location anyone seen the clicker
that was that was it
so I mean this is it's a game that keeps
on giving
it's even better when when you know
they're head coaching changes which
there always are so there's always a
draft it's it's kind of it just is it
refreshes itself yes so we figured we'd
give you the photograph that was taken
it the owners meeting oh yes a little
bit less than a month ago right around
this time in March and there it is right
there on the screen so many of our
viewers so many of our listeners know
what we're looking at right there yeah
oh they remember you know they're we
figured we'd give you Doug Peterson
who's in the back row on his on his
rascal and yep bumped Jay Gruden as the
photographs are being taken so Jays in
some sort of Heimlich maneuver type of a
posture right couldn't take another shot
no one for safety I guess I don't know
not one for safe actually has a position
called safe just in case multiple
shutter clean Jon Gruden always looks
like he's squinting so what what leaps
out at you from this okay look I don't
mean to disappoint the listeners of your
program who now expect me to do this
every time there is no way I can talk
about anything except Andy Reid's in
that photograph he is a he is a black
hold of attention people say it was
amazing that they took a photo of a
black hole I think it's amazing that
Auntie Rita sitting on the middle of
this photograph front row in in shorts
probably with ankle socks
maybe we hope for his wife there's
something in his in his pocket um could
be a lottery ticket I don't know what I
don't know what that shirt is it a
Hawaiian pattern it could be I think it
is
I also the first time I saw it I went
he's bald because I totally seen him in
hats I've never seen him in anything
else and then really the main takeaway
does he looks like Wilford Brimley from
cocoon I see that and I go where's Hume
Cronyn
there is Jessica Tandy where are they
standing definitely not in this
photograph oh de Graaff he's a man
spreading masterpiece in the middle of I
bet they're the centerpiece of man
spreading you know what type of stepdad
he would be right there or oh man I mean
even get to the eye I couldn't even get
to that but if I had to make something
up yes I would just say going on the
Wilford Brimley and oatmeal I think he's
the kind of stepdad I would just say hey
you're gonna finish that you can finish
that and it's anything it could be
breakfast could be lunch it could just
be like a soda homework it could be
homework - you're gonna finish that I'm
gonna finish that well that's a
different tone but yes yes that that's a
more authoritative tone although maybe
he's the kind of stepdad that doesn't
want any food to go to waste you know
you're gonna fit you know you're gonna
finish that he could be the kind of
stepdad that like gives his dog the rest
of his dinner that he doesn't want to
eat he could do that yeah he does look
funny don't feed the dog it she's fine
she's fine I thought of all the ones
that you would also be zooming in on his
Kliff Kingsbury yeah who looks like you
know the new stepdad who's dressing in
his in his finely tailored I mean look
I'm gonna but let's showing off the pecs
and
and they had his finely tailored sort of
Italian button-down shirt yeah shoes the
shoes probably cost more than Andy
Reid's entire getup without a doubt but
you want to know what it also looks like
he's the guy who's not allowed to let
the Stanley Cup over his head because
he's in accounting oh look like
accountants in comparison to Andy Reid
in that photograph and Belichick made it
to this I mean think about that I know
it
he made Belichick look like well-dressed
when has that ever happen when has that
ever happened
oh my gosh life and pieces returns to
CBS this very Thursday at 8:30 p.m.
Eastern Time this is a welcome sight for
sore eyes sir Congrats on on the season
for coming back right there what is it
like on the set with all these guys
getting back together as you as you did
for so much longer I mean we have a
ridiculous amount of fun on the show and
it really sort of shows when all the
bloopers that we have they are always
sending us the blooper reels to to
approve but you know we have a really
good time I mean it is a large group of
people so there is we do have our own
sort of family dynamic yes
and so there's some land mines and
things that you want to you know make
sure okay maybe don't talk to that
person until they've had their coffee
maybe make you know is that person
didn't get their turn around let's maybe
make sure that we we treat that person a
little bit special that's the one that
you need to take camping yeah that's the
one you need to take camping there is uh
there there you know you just think
about you and Dianne Wiest just think
about her DN way stuff I would love the
break her camping
she is so New York that I don't think
that's ever gonna happen I don't think
that's ever gonna speaking of so New
York I've never asked you this and I
can't believe I'm using this real estate
to bring this yeah right here has Barbra
Streisand ever showed him yes she has
yes James Brolin she's married to James
Brolin who plays my dad on the show and
and he brings Barbra around every now
and again I worked with Barbra a few
years ago on a movie so we actually kind
of like know each other
okay but yeah he brought Barbara to the
to the wrap party and I remember they
were incredibly fascinated by tater tots
hmm that they were something you can
order on that food truck that we had at
our wrap party honey they got tater tots
oh they were very excited about tater
tots so this is just a good example and
by the way I don't know if they ordered
the tater tots or not there was just a
subject of discussion for a good two
minutes but it's a good example of even
barbara streisand
arguably one of the most famous people
on the planet when the most talented
singers of all time she's still gonna
have that conversation that your grandma
was also farther than AB which is tater
tot they got tater tots and it could be
some variation of why do I want to buy
tater tots here I could make big tater
tots at home ya don't know take a lot of
the conversations I've had with Barbara
in in in the life and pieces settings
have been about food which makes me go I
love this woman
Yeah right you know I know she's royalty
but the bottom line is this you can take
the girl out of Brooklyn
but you will never take the Brooklyn out
of the girl I mean if she's from
Brooklyn
yeah she's got tater tots in the freezer
Russia she probably suggested defrost
yes and serve up yes absolutely yeah are
we segwaying into a Tater Tot commercial
I don't think we heart I think we should
only need to look into so just one more
thing you know hey are you gonna finish
those tater tots by the way and you
would say that to Josh Brolin yes so
let's see em rollin no no I know that
but Josh would be his kid that's the rig
that's barely fit inside the Rich Eisen
should Honda wall right there I had to
pull next to the left leg squeeze mining
thing yeah there's a little awning above
it you know let's you know what the you
know what the height is I had to drive
around that Wow and I
gumption well I remembered I had I came
early cuz I'm like I'm not a hundred
percent sure I'm gonna say well you got
here early yeah that wasn't a hundred
percent sure traffic was light and you
yeah it's great because I just arrived
at places early now and that's a
box-spring on your roof it looks like
yes that's what it is yeah hey sleeps
great I sleep great
there we go rock that's you know making
things uncomfortable it's fantastic I
even have little little things I can
stick under the the tires so I can sort
of even out the trucks you go yeah and
so you just show up early and everyone's
like wow come on so mindful of my time
by showing up so early
he's such a professional and you're like
no I've got a rig on my own yeah yeah my
rod yeah fantastic
all right hankerchief calm we're gonna
talk about that when we come back for
the television only segment about your
ready-made handkerchiefs from California
and they're called handkerchief yeah
doctor they're amazing Oh buddy this is
your new business everyone should go
again to Hanks kerchiefs dot-com or on
Twitter at Hanks kerchiefs and that's
the Instagram site as well for all that
we're gonna hit on it thanks for coming
in sir thanks for having the radio
audience again that is Colin Hanks
follow him on Twitter and Instagram at
Colin Hanks as well life in pieces
Thursday at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app